over the past decade none of batman's
growing family of friends have proven
quite so exciting as batwoman
especially now that she has finally made
her small screen debut
but just who is batwoman here's a look
at the untold truth behind one of dc's
most
fascinating characters kathy kane the
original batwoman debuted in detective
comics number 233
in july 1956. unfortunately the
character wasn't introduced by dc
out of any real desire to expand
batman's universe
instead kathy kane was concocted to
combat some scurrilous rumors
about the caped crusader in 1954
the psychiatrist frederick wortham had
published seduction of the innocent
a highly dubious yet influential
treatise on the dangers of superhero
comics
in this book wertham had this to say
about batman and robin's relationship
it is like a wish dream of two
homosexuals living together
holy romeo and juliet wertham's book
would go on to spark
full-blown congressional hearings and
devastate the world of genre fiction
and while most superhero titles escaped
unscathed
batman's editors decided that they
needed to restore the appearance of
heteronormativity to gotham city
thus kathy kane the batwoman as a
wealthy socialite and former circus
performer whose admiration for batman
drove her to a life of crime fighting
kathy was a love interest in the style
of superman's ever popular lois lane
of course bruce wayne has a thing for
her but she only has eyes for batman
and to complicate matters he knows her
secret identity but
she doesn't know his this dynamic
produced some fairly interesting early
adventures and
even introduced a sidekick in the form
of cathy's niece betty
the original batgirl who was a similarly
positioned
love interest for robin in the end
though kathy proved to be more popular
with readers than she was with incoming
batman editor
julius schwartz who pared down the
batman family dramatically when he took
over
in the early 60s while kathy kane was
eventually phased out of the comics the
idea of keeping a woman in the batman
family persisted elsewhere
specifically on television in 1967
at the height of the batman tv show's
popularity the producers decided to
expand their cast
and introduce a new batgirl glad to have
you flanking this bad girl
the tv show tied the new batgirl to an
existing character by introducing her as
barbara gordon
the daughter of gotham city's solemn and
stentorian police commissioner the
viewers were clued in on her secret
identity but
unlike kathy kane batman and robin
initially had no idea who she really was
batgirl proved to be a reliably popular
member of the tv show's bat
family and soon enough barbara gordon
was introduced in the comics too the
comic book version of barbara was just
as popular with fans as her tv
counterpart
as a result the character served as
batgirl until 1988
and then stepped back into the role from
2011 to the present
even when she wasn't batgirl barbara
regularly featured as
oracle an incredibly skilled hacker who
often provided vital information to
batman
and the justice league when batman
family launched in 1975
the second issue asked readers to write
in with their picks for which secondary
batman characters they wanted to see
featured alongside batgirl and robin
apparently the response was strong
enough that they featured a reprint of
an early batwoman story in the next
issue
by then the fan letters were demanding a
proper comeback for kathy kane in number
10
these readers finally got their wish
when batwoman came out of retirement for
a team-up story with her successor
batgirl at the end of the story kathy
offers barbara the title of batwoman
babs refuses however claiming that while
it was an honor
there can be only one batwoman soon
enough though
there'd be no bat women at all four
years later
in detective comics number 485 that
woman is killed
by the league of assassins that was the
last reader saw of the main universe's
kathy kane for nearly 30 years
and in the mid-80s crisis on infinite
earths rearranged the timeline so that
she never existed
at all in 1999 barbara gordon was busy
being oracle
and kathy kane had been written out of
existence so there was nothing stopping
dc from teasing a potential new female
bat character
in the pages of the no man's land story
arc no man's land follows the heroes and
villains of gotham in the aftermath of a
devastating earthquake which leaves the
entire city as little more than a
post-apocalyptic ruin
all but abandoned by the us government
gotham becomes a battleground for the
countless gangs and supervillains who
are vying for domination
what's worse batman has been missing for
three months
so naturally someone puts on a bat
costume and starts claiming territory in
his name
this particular batwoman turns out to be
the huntress but she
isn't the only one to wear the
distinctive costume during no man's land
at the end of the story the cowl is
passed on to cassandra kane
a teenager who is trained since birth to
become an assassin
with the huntress back in her normal
identity cassandra decides to become the
new batgirl
leaving the door open for an all-new
batwoman to appear
in 2006 the dc universe jumped forward
by a year
and then explained everything in a
year-long weekly mini-series called 52.
the series set the stage for plenty of
major developments
the most prominent and long-lasting of
which was the introduction of the
all-new batwoman
kate kane not to be confused with the
silver ages kathy kane
kate sported a brand new black and red
costume designed by alex ross
she also made headlines after she was
introduced as dc's highest profile
lesbian character
especially once she took over detective
comics as its headlining star
while kate used batman's iconography in
order to strike fear into gotham city's
criminals
she was dramatically different from the
caped crusader she had military training
was significantly less averse to
firearms and her equivalent to alfred
was her father
a retired general who provided her with
the experimental military hardware
there was however one key similarity
between kate
and bruce she too was driven to fight
crime after seeing her family killed in
front of her
in this case her mother and twin sister
detective comics number 858 dives into
kate kane's origin story
and the following issue deals with her
dismissal from the united states
military academy during her senior year
while training at west point kate is
accused of being in violation of article
125
of the uniform military code of justice
just in case you're not totally up to
speed on the specifics of military law
that's the article concerning
homosexuality which was once used
to keep lgbtq people out of the military
while kate is offered the chance to
claim that it was
all a misunderstanding she instead
chooses to leave west point
and never fulfill her lifelong dream of
serving in the army
naturally that sense of integrity has
been one of her defining characteristics
ever since
it's worth noting that this story was
originally published in 2009
when the official policy of the military
was don't ask
don't tell meaning that gay people could
serve just as long as they were in the
closet
only two years later in 2011 that policy
was changed and article 125 was
officially repealed from the ucmj
that means that eventually kate's origin
may have to be retconned
however considering this would be a
fictional retcon that comes at the cost
of real world progress
it's no surprise that the creators of
that origin story
are absolutely fine with it when dc
rebooted their entire line in 2011 as
the new 52
batwoman got her first ongoing series
co-written by j.h williams iii
and william hayden blackman the most
notable addition to batwoman's roster
was maggie sawyer who first met kate
during her headlining run
in detective comics and quickly became
the character's love interest
maggie was originally introduced in the
superman books of the 90s
as a police officer in the metropolis
special crimes unit
back then she was one of the most
prominent gay characters in comics
playing a major role in superman's
ongoing saga in the early 2000s she was
transferred to gotham city's police
department in gotham central
a book that not coincidentally was
co-written by greg
raka one of kate's creators the
relationship between maggie and kate
became a huge part of the series
and led to a groundbreaking moment in
batwoman number 17
when kate proposes to maggie
unfortunately the marriage never came to
be
the editors at dc forbade the wedding
from taking place
a controversial decision that prompted
williams and blackman to walk out
in protest dc insisted that the decision
wasn't made as a result of an anti-lgbtq
agenda
but rather because of an editorial shift
that turned against marriage in
general with publisher dan de dio saying
that quote heroes shouldn't have happy
personal lives
but what what should we call you reign
miss parade
kane kate kane over the last decade
or so the cw has formed a full-on dc
multiverse on television with a core
roster featuring some of the most iconic
dc heroes
of all time occasionally the aeroverse
shows would cross over in massive
team-up events
one of these was the elseworlds story in
2018 which introduced a brand new
character to the arrowverse
batwoman as portrayed by ruby rose the
cw's take on batwoman exists in a gotham
city where batman disappeared
three years earlier leading to a surge
in crime and the need for a new
bat-themed vigilante crime fighter
in september 2019 the fully-fledged
batwoman series debuted with rose at the
forefront
and the cw ordered a second season just
a few weeks
later playing a major comic book
character on screen could be a career
defining move
for almost any actor and for a while it
looked like ruby rose would follow that
upward trajectory
however in may 2020 just a few months
after the cw asked for a second season
of batwoman
rose announced that she would be
departing the series in a statement she
said
this was not a decision i made lightly
as i have the utmost respect for the
cast
crew and everyone involved with the show
thank you to everyone who made season
one a success
i am truly grateful so why would an
actor walk away from a plum roll and a
regular gig on network television
variety later reported that rose had a
deep distaste for the series's long
shooting days which
led to tension on the set in the end a
mutual decision was made between rose
the cw
and warner brothers to find a new actor
to portray batwoman
in the same news reports announcing ruby
rose's exit from batwoman
the show's production company warner
brothers made it clear that this wasn't
going to spell the end for the series
within days of rose's departure it was
announced that kate kane would also be
cut from the show
in favor of a new character who uses the
batwoman alias
a leaked casting call revealed that
producers were looking for an actor
quote
female mid late 20s any ethnicity to
portray ryan wilder the new batwoman
who is supposed to be quote likable
messy a little goofy
and nothing like kate kane however
showrunner caroline dries
almost took the easier route of finding
a new actor to play kate
kane in an interview at the atx festival
at home
she explained i did consider the soap
opera version for a hot minute because
selfishly we already had a couple
episodes written
and transition wise it would be seamless
ultimately aeroverse overseer greg
berlanti made the decision to
introduce a new character along with a
fresh actor in the end
the new batwoman was revealed to be
javicia leslie
known for her roles on the bet crime
show the family business
and the cbs drama god friended me her
first appearance on batwoman came in a
january 2021 episode titled
appropriately enough whatever happened
to kate kane
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one